I want to share the most beautiful
equation in math with you okay so
actually this is literally if you search
Google the most beautiful equation in
math yeah you will find it so this thing
I might need to use a little bit of the
board I'll just write this pi we already
know what pi is right there's another
number in math which is called I this is
the square root of -1 so somehow I equal
to the square root of -1 which you're
not allowed to do there's no way you can
multiply two numbers together and get a
negative one well there is if you allow
what are called complex numbers or
imaginary numbers so that's this I you
can multiply those two together you can
get even more crazy number not only
something doesn't end but it's not even
a real number but there's another number
in math also and that number is called E
and E appears on a lot of these
scientific calculators is another number
which is just like pi in the sense that
it's transcendental doesn't stop
anywhere and also there isn't a there
isn't a very nice way to express what it
is so this one goes by 2.71828 and so on
actually this number is also quite
impressive it's one eight two eight one
eight two eight 45 90 45 and more digits
beyond there okay so a bunch of nice
numbers but this e actually comes also
somewhere else in mathematics even
though I told you this doesn't have sent
any nicer repeating decimal or even
terminating decimal with E you can get a
by saying suppose I have a box of
chocolates with a hundred chocolates and
I drop them all on the ground and I
tried to put them all back in this is
like these nice chocolates but
everything's different right you can ask
like what's the probability that every
chocolate went back in the wrong spot
and that probability becomes very close
to 1 over E that's this and the more
chocolates you have the closer it is to
this anyway three crazy numbers it turns
out that if you take E and raise it to
that then I can finish the equation with
two more numbers like the most basic
numbers in math are 1 and 0 and this is
true so what's going on here is I've
just put together 3 completely
ridiculous numbers and they together
make negative 1 for all of the
of the nest that was here because all
come back in together right here and
this is this is a this is an Avis called
Euler's identity and it is actually the
most beautiful equation in math because
it combines all of these different
constants together
there's your pi there but suddenly the
pi got joined with all these other ones
so there's some other other other fun
parts here - have you seen this is the
shirts with the PI and the I the joke
where pi says get real and I says be
rational right there they're basically
calling each other out so I seen those
shirts ever since I was in high school
of like the speech bubble get real be
rational it's like the pot calling the
kettle black but actually that should
that shirt should have one more punch
line the last punch line should be let
me let me write the joke first this one
says get real and this one says be
rational the correct way to put the
punchline on this joke if I should say
join me and will be one so of course
that's a negative one right there but
somehow this was this this punchline the
joke was never said before and though we
thought of this joke about two years ago
American it we have we already great
t-shirts with it